let's jump to this story here from the
new york post las vegas official accused
of killing reporter will remain in
office what and get paid what
okay so this is a democrat
and he's there wearing some kind of what
is that a clean suit or something
bio mask it's a smock so uh this guy has
been arrested innocent until proven
guilty
charged with the murder he's arrested on
murder suspicion of a journalist who was
who was covering running hit pieces
and so this guy
they find his dna at the scene that
that's that's what happened right olivia
i want to make correct yes
he's been arrested
and he's still
in office he's still getting paid he's
wearing a dexter suit when this reporter
runs into him what is going on here so
uh how many people do you know could
keep their jobs when they go to jail for
murder when they're arrested and charged
awaiting trial well well tim we also
have to understand that you know
politicians murder people all the time
and they get away with
do you understand what happens behind
the scene of power oh yeah this is the
one time you saw it did you see the wars
that they started do you see the drone
bombs that they sent over i mean if this
guy's gonna go to jail barack obama
right now turn yourself in for the
assassination of uh
and his son and a 16 year old american
citizen that was executed by you
personally when you signed off on the
order to kill an american 16 year old
child
and he got to stay in office he got to
stay in office he got a government
paycheck so you know why should this guy
get kicked out of office government
obama killed an american kid
literally killed a 16 year old american
citizen abdulrahman i love saying that
as often as possible and this is not the
first time i mean i mean presidents have
started conflicts have started wars have
started even
you know done actions that have led to
the end of many people's lives i just i
would love to see obama turning himself
in to the las vegas police and he'd be
like well if he's gone i guess so what
yeah and it was on and they just locked
him up and threw him in a cell and it
was a number of american citizens it
wasn't just one yeah it was it was
around seven to two eight the number is
still unknown because there there was a
lot of covert ops surrounding a lot of
these actions but but essentially barack
obama literally signed off on a lot of
these executions that without a judge
without a trial without a jury executed
american citizens and killed them and
that's the power that he gave donald
trump donald trump uh made sure that the
the accounting and records of it wasn't
public and he gave the power to the
pentagon to make these decisions and he
made sure that the records weren't
public trump had too much faith in the
military he really revered these guys
and boy did that screw him over in a lot
of ways especially with those who lied
to him about syria but um
was it was a collateral murder was that
bush that was bush right i believe that
was bush and uh chelsea manning uh that
released that footage was that true the
footage i'm wondering i think i think it
might have been under bush i'm not sure
it might have been under obama because i
think that was released in like 2010
wasn't it but happened under i mean it
was old video footage right what
happened under bush right all right the
reason i bring that up is i thought it
was bush because it just shows you how
these powers get passed down yeah that
obama is promising you all the bells and
whistles and then you know he gets in he
kills people all the same so uh you know
what throwing it back to this story
about this guy in vegas
um
luke is right like are we now going to
change our policies i'm surprised this
guy actually got charged i suppose
i i don't know honestly what's what's
the difference really barack obama
signed off on a drone strike on a
civilian restaurant in yemen a country
we were not at war with and he blew up a
16 year old american citizen who had
committed no crimes
so i just i gotta wonder like that to me
is actually worse for a few reasons
first of all he killed a child
second of all he killed he blew up a
civilian restaurant firing missiles into
countries around a war with i'm like man
it just compounds and so much worse
and then it's also just like you know i
understand it's not as as important but
the tens of millions of dollars it cost
to do that now you're stealing our money
too and this guy this guy gets gets
arrested the first thing thinking about
this story because this was a very
interesting story i actually tweeted
about this journalist passing away
because he was an investigative
journalist he was also one of the few
journalists that was actually correctly
investigating the las vegas shooting
which a lot of people have totally
forgot about which we still don't have
an explanation
we still don't have an official
explanation to exactly what happened in
las vegas during that during this mass
shooting event that of course
has so many people push for for gun
control but but more importantly i
originally thought maybe this was
somehow connected i i put this story out
before the politician was even connected
to this story but the politician who is
accused of killing him was also caught
by this journalist cheating on his wife
this journalist ended his political
career he he was a high-profile democrat
in las vegas uh but but automatically
hearing the story i i thought about what
bill clinton said about house of cards
if you remember uh house of cards it was
a famous netflix show with kevin spacey
friends of all friends and of course
jeffrey epstein but but bill clinton
said that that house of cards was 99
real wow and in house of cards the
president assassinates a journalist and
kills them yeah kevin's basically kills
them so so that that automatically makes
me think of this there's a lot of things
happening behind the seat of power that
we still don't know about there's
there's this meme with an iceberg
showing the corruption that we know that
we know about and then the corruption
that we don't know about being this huge
piece of ice underneath the the water
and i think this is the current reality
that we're dealing with and if we would
know exactly what politicians the really
sinister the really bad ones were up to
we would be shocked and i don't i think
it would
change our whole political landscape
i do think that trump was very different
from obama and from bush i certainly
think he made mistakes in who he trusted
but i i i actually think trump was an
outsider i think they didn't expect him
to win i think he did want to end the
wars i think he made a bunch of mistakes
i think he signed up on a bunch of bad
orders
but uh
you look at how hard they're going after
him he did sign the abraham accords he
did try and bring peace say you know
north korea and crossing into the dmz
and things like that
and i know a lot of people they don't
they don't think it's enough you know we
had dave smith on the show and
mashterray last week and dave said he's
still doing bad and so that shouldn't be
the standard so you know my view is just
like
someone super chat to this i thought to
them instead they said this problem was
created over 100 years you're not going
to solve it in 100 days you can't expect
one president to come in and then just
snap their fingers and just end all of
the really really bad awful stuff
but why does that be the president
because when i you know see stories like
this like you know where are all the men
yeah like where are the men in our
government
you know if you look at you know trump's
presidency if you're just taking that as
a litmus test it's like you had an
investigation the entire time he was
president
so how is it
that his political enemies were able to
roll out mueller and the things that
were going on with
russia the things that were going on
um how are they able to have a non-stop
investigation non-stop uh political
power
like where where are the men that are
constitutional where are the american
men to stand up to this type of stuff
not in politics yeah well it's just
interesting because i think what made
trump so appealing to
everybody was that he had balls yeah
they that he got on tv and he spoke his
mind and talking about you know his
growth in the black community is like
that resonated with with with black
america is that you had a man a
masculine man that got on tv desantis
has that as well yeah but all the
rappers loved donald trump trump was all
it was
all the music videos but it's like you
know you see this going on in las vegas
it's like is there no men is there no
any like who do we have in the senate
right now
i mean you know you see these little
clips where it's like oh ted cruz rose
so and so or whatever but it's like no
like
you're not you're just you're just you
know you're you're you're playing a part
but you know our country is headed in a
downward spiral like where are the men
like yeah it's all theatrics i mean and
and washington dc i mean there's no real
you know i'm not i'm not bought and paid
for by any politician so it's like i can
i can criticize them from a in an
objective way as a citizen of the united
states but it's like
all the politicians who
are on their so-called republican side
many of them are themselves corrupt at
least they demonstrate that i mean if
you look at what they're saying on
twitter and what their actual voting
record is many of them are no different
than the people on the other side of the
aisle and so to the extent that it comes
to
uh standing up for true law and order i
mean the inscription on the supreme
court uh building is literally you know
equal justice under the law but they're
not applying that you know what i mean
and so there's no there's no real
uh men who who love this country are
fighting for the con the constitution of
these united states in the senate or in
the congress like how is there a
non-stop investigation on trump like
where like is there no one on the other
side like do i mean are is no one
curious about some of the things on the
other side like where like when is
so you know you got to go vote 57 days i
think it is that we're at 57 well vote
yeah voting voting will do so much but i
mean hopefully there will be some men
that will step up and but the thing is
too like people have to kind of get it
out of their head that the only election
that matters is the president of the
united states you know what i mean yeah
and that being said too some men but i
kind of feel like marjorie taylor green
is gonna be the one who actually goes
heavy into the investigations and stuff
there are some women who uh
carrie yeah carrie lake
yeah she uh she's been supportive of our
of our recent projects so i mean you
know when i say men i'm just saying like
men that you know will stand up and like
we need some masculinity some truth you
know
you have these little glimpses of it but
it's just it just might it's just
mind-blowing that you know non-stop
investigations committees you know
government spending on investigating i
mean you're using taxpayer dollars to
basically you know
uh
grab power for yourself and and and just
longing for the day and i think again
like that's what was so cool about trump
look yeah you know love him or hate him
it's like it was just cool to see a man
on tv
you know flip the bird at the media it
was just cool it was cool to you know
you know i remember those fake news yeah
i remember the press conferences like
how exciting i remember like kicking
like oh my goodness like i've never you
know it it made me uncomfortable because
i hadn't even been conditioned to seeing
just weak
politicians but all all republican
politics is these days is basically
placating the left uh to try to you know
in a sense play it safe so as to come to
some kind of common ground to keep some
remnants of things as they were that's
basically what republican politics is
there is no uh true kind of
intentionality in terms of preserving
the republic of the united states i mean
you literally had the president of the
united states talking about we need to
preserve our democracy and a lot of
people have it in their head that
america is a democracy
like nobody challenged him in terms of
the mainstream media of like well no
actually we're not a democracy we're a
dem we're a constitutional republic like
nobody checked him on that and so it's a
problem but to but you know back to the
story about you know this politician who
will you know keep their position who
will continually get paid um this is in
a sense like the same thing that has
been going on in terms of you know
politicians being above the law they are
an elitist class and
you know we are expected as citizens to
kind of go along with it yeah you made a
good point just really quickly the
republicans now have almost the same
policies as the democrats nearly had 10
years ago and it's almost the same exact
thing that they're just vying for so i
especially agree with you i don't have a
lot of hope in voting but when it comes
to the men i think a lot of them have
been sterilized i think a lot of them
have been chemically castrated and i
think there also is a bigger spiritual
and health fight happening that is
affecting our current landscape that i
think is also worth talking about
definitely yeah we are at spiritual we
are in spiritual war right now yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you